你男朋友找到你也真是早大霉了，你随便换个人早就跟你分手了。我不认为你的父母是真的爱你，我认为你的父母是非常虚荣的，我认为你的父母是有毒的父母，你就是典型的杉菜。我是17年进入广东四线小城市体制内，然后在单位里边儿，18年的时候和同事在一起了。20年的时候因为口罩原因，家里就周转不开了呢，就是基本上把家里边儿的一些负债情况就跟我说了。然后这个时候呢，男朋友就拿出大概10个W左右吧，就来帮助我。但是就是这个钱对于家里边儿来讲杯水车薪，所以呢，我就想整体知道家里边儿到底一共有多少外债。我就跟家里边算了个账，大概是200多W的主要原因是父亲为了就是把之前欠的那些外债还清，买了一套门面房。但是买的这套门面房手里边又没有本金，所以就跟各种银行呀，像什么各种平台去贷款买了这个你门面房导致欠债更多了。然后呢，我们商量了一下，就是说先把这个商品房卖掉，卖掉之后，还了已经还了银行里的一大部分债，现在就剩平台的债，大概有三四十个。然后没有办法了，男朋友就把我家的房子买下来了。第一个就是能拿出一部分钱，第二个就是能让父母有个住的地方。当时银行批贷款就是。
贷了30W之后，我就想着是把家里边儿亲戚这些钱全部还完，至于平台嘛，反挣着慢慢还嘛。父母不同意，就觉得说要面子什么的，所以没拗过他就把平台的钱全部还了，然后亲戚的债就欠下了。现在呢，亲戚大概一共欠着60多，有20多是用舅舅的名义贷的，有20多父亲是主贷人，我是担保人，还有7W吧，就是母亲手机贷的，剩下的其他就是私人的，在这差不多就60多W吧。现在面临的情况就是父母从小对我很好，那时候房子买的8000块钱，他为了让我学钢琴贷款买了一万五的钢琴，所以就是他们从小对我都很好。现在父母在上班，在一个厂里边儿，每个人大概一个月工资就是4000多块钱吧，让他们去还这个钱，就是还不完。现在我和男朋友商量过之后，就觉得说把我们家现在这套房子卖掉。卖掉的话，大概就是还过贷款，能剩差不多三十五六。拿出二十再给他们。把我父亲是主贷人，我担保的这个，因为利息最高，把这个先还掉。还掉之后呢，差不多能剩30左右嘛。我是去年考到我家这边的体制内了，我把公积金全提了，公积金里有18个，然后把这18。
的再给他们还掉之后，父母差不多就能剩十几二十W了。这样的话，他们一年能挣个8万8W到9W。他们马上就把这个账给还完了。然后，我们家里的情况就是会由负循环变成正向循环，也就不再欠钱了。但是，你知道龙飞姐就是这些年我跟男朋友说的一点存款都没有。这10万W基本上就是我俩最后的钱了，所以我就在想我应该怎么办呢？是帮助他们还完呢，还是说去年的时候他考到我们家这边的省会城市了？然后我是去年的时候考到我们家这边一个县城了。我俩现在是两地，然后男朋友的意思就是说还吧，因为我不是那种狠心的人，没办法放着他们不管，这个钱迟早都得我还，他说，与其这样还，不如现在直接把所有的钱能还的都还了，也算是我们俩就是能做到自己最大的程度了。
你今年多大了？我31了，家里有个弟弟，就是完全指望不住五年前老大的男朋友。30了，男朋友家里爸爸妈妈是干啥的？男朋友单亲家庭，母亲带这，他跟两个姐姐长大，也是农民，把家里没有什么存款，就一路这么陪我走来。你男朋友找到你也真是倒大霉了，真的，我跟你讲啊，姐妹啊，我给你捋一捋好不好好，我不认为你的父母是真的爱你，我认为你的父母是非常虚荣的，我认为你的父母是有毒的父母。原因是什么？好不好？你听听我的理论啊。
好，如果你的父母本身自己没有这个能力，一个月挣4000块钱，然后要花18000块钱，1万多块钱给女儿去买一台钢琴，你知道对于女儿来说是想融入的圈子，他又融入不进去自己的圈子里面，自己又是矛盾的，你理解是什么意思吗？
就有点像什么呢？杉菜的父母省吃俭用，吃糠咽菜，然后送杉菜，非要去读贵族学校一样。在贵族学校那个圈子里面又容不下杉菜。在杉菜自己的朋友圈子里面，到时候又很难找对象。你就是典型的杉菜，就是你爸爸妈妈本身没有这个能力，没有这个经济实力，对吧？一个月挣3000块钱，4000块钱的时候给你买1万多的钢琴，你不觉得你就是杉菜吗？
就是条件好的那个环境，你都融不进去，条件差的环境，你都看不上。我不认为你爸妈是这种方式，是爱你。这是一种反向的反向的有毒的父母，就是其他的有毒的父母，是克扣自己的孩子。你的这个有毒的父母是把孩子托举到一个不属于他的世界去，反而也挺吓人。而且，他们能够亲戚朋友的钱，平台的钱，各种钱都去借，他们本就是心高气傲的人，本就是不甘于过平凡日子的人，所以他们的苦难是他们造成的，不是你造成的。
嗯，我个人觉得啊，你应该跟你这个男朋友好好的关起门来过日子。我再说一遍哦，你认真听哦，你不要以为他们内容是对你的爱，这是一方面，另一方面，他们的苦难不是你造成的。你应该是跟你的男朋友关系本来好好的过日子，你男朋友做到今时今日可以说是仁至义尽。你随便换个人早就跟你分手了，随便换个人早就拜拜了我菲姐有时候很矛盾，就是我父母吧。你说他没有脚踏实地的干吧，他在脚踏实地的干，但是不知道是因为他们的认知，还是什么的就是导致这些年一直在负债。他们也是那种勤勤本本，就是前些年一直挣不做生意，不这是你对他们的错误的认知，他们就是心高气傲。
他们就是想一口吃个胖子，我说句难听点的话，好不好？您直接讲，我甚至认为他们从小超出自己消费水平去那么培养你要培养，你要弹钢琴啊，什么的大概心里指望着你找个有钱人呢，心里指望着你攀个高枝呢啊，真正靠谱的脚踏实地的人。
为什么拿舅舅去贷款，拿亲生女儿去贷款，拿这个去贷款，拿那个去贷款？你弟弟贷款了没？我弟弟前两年也有贷款，我也给他擦屁股。这两年我管不了，我的意思是你爸有你爸妈有没有让你弟弟去签担保啊？那没有啊，那为什么没让你弟弟先担保？为什么不了？我弟弟现在应该真心都已经是黑的了，你什么时候才能醒悟过来啊？
你的这个父母啊，对你的这个爱啊，是一种压力，是一种负担，并不是真正的父母之爱子则谓之计生远。父母之爱子是真的要为自己的孩子将来去考虑的。你是一个体制内的人，你去给他们签担保，你想什么呢？你这事儿，你就必须跟你的男朋友齐心协力的好好过日子。你之所以现在日子过不好，你是没看清，你是老觉得啊，爸妈对我付出了多少，爸妈对我有多好，我怎么怎么地的不忍心。你没有看清事情的本质，你现在的苦难怎么来的，认真想。
好吧，知道了，姐，谢谢，嗯嗯，拜拜。我是不是讲这话又得罪一帮父母？我就是这么想问题的。我觉得啊，就是我们作为父母托举孩子，是不是也得量力而行？如果我一个月就能挣3000块钱，就能挣4000块钱。我是不会给我女儿去买一个什么13000块钱，18000块钱的钢琴的，去这种去托举她的，因为你超出你自己能力范围，你把她去托举到那个贵族学校、私立学校，他融入不进去，他会很痛苦的，姐妹们。
我直播间有没有这样的女孩子，就说你爸妈呃从小到大负债托举你，负债送你去上这个什么艺术班，负债让你去上那个什么艺术班。你在那个艺术班里你能融入的进去吗？人家可能那样的孩子啊，人家可能随便买个买个鞋2000块，随便买个镯子3000块，随便买个发卡六七百，你能融入的进去吗？你根本融入不进去，你融入不进去的话，你会很痛苦的。我给大家举一个真实的例子好不好，比如说你们家龙飞姐，我也融入不进去那样高端的场合。
也会有一些化妆品的品牌啊，说要请龙飞姐去有个红毯啊，搞个答谢宴啊，穿个晚礼服啊，就就搞个发布会啊什么的也会有人邀请的。但你们家龙飞姐的就不用我拒绝，客服的小伙伴直接就拒绝掉了，因为他们知道融不进去的圈子不要强融，就像刚才那样的父母，他把自己的女儿托举到那个什么学一万多的钢琴啊，买1万多的钢琴，呃，钢琴课又得花那么多钱。其实这女孩儿她真的，她就是运气好，找了这么个好的男朋友，她但凡要是运气不好的话，要换个男朋友的话，现在这个女孩三十几岁了啊，肯定被男朋友踹，然后欠一身的债。就这样的父母，你真的觉得她爱你吗？姐妹，你认真想一想，她真的爱你吗？父母之爱子则谓之计生远，一定要为儿女的将来打算，为儿女的前途打算，为儿女是否能够自洽，是否能够幸福。在他那个环境下生活的话，他快不快乐，一定要为这方面去打算。